[Music]
on this Wednesday night calls for
sweeping changes to policing he didn't
deserve to die over $20 the message
George Floyd's brother delivered to us
lawmakers is that what a black man is
worth the RCMP Commissioner on racism in
the force that have been struggling with
the definitions that systemic racism
busts our armed police always the answer
calls for a change in response to mental
health crises kovat 19 testing
reliability why a negative result
doesn't mean you aren't infected and 34
years later a murder case finally closed
is often compared with the assassination
of JFK police say they know who killed
swedish prime minister Olaf Palma but
can't lay charges
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
in the span of just two weeks there's
been a transformation in the discussion
around racial injustice and policing in
the United States and around the world
all of it driven by the reaction to the
death of George Floyd at the hands of
Minneapolis Police in Washington today
lawmakers began hearings on a proposal
for sweeping legislation to improve
policing eliminate racial profiling and
police brutality the first witness was
felonious Floyd who just yesterday
buried his brother George I'm tired I'm
tired of pain pain you feel when you
watch something like that when you watch
your big brother who you looked up to
for your whole life died died begging
for his mom I'm here to ask you to make
it stop
issues of racism and policing are on the
agenda here in Canada too Global News
asked the Commissioner of the RCMP today
whether she thinks there's systemic
racism in her force here's how she
responded I don't to say systemically
that we have racism I think systemically
there's racism
in in most organizations and I don't
think the RCMP is immune to that we'll
hear more from the RCMP commissioner in
just a moment first though Jackson
Prosecco and the calls in Washington to
make policing part of the solution and
not the problem less than 24 hours after
George Floyd was laid to rest his
brother full onus faced lawmakers in
Washington pressing them to ensure a
lasting legacy comes from this moment of
national grief it is all you to make
sure his death is not in vain after two
weeks of protests the first hearing on
police reform took a hard look at the
treatment of black Americans we must
acknowledge that law enforcement's past
contains institutional racism and
justices and brutality there were
questions about how far to go as calls
to defund police grow louder Angela
Underwood
it's brother a federal officer was
killed as protests turned violent last
week in California it is a ridiculous
solution to proclaim that defunding
police departments is a solution to
produce police brutality and
discrimination because it's not a
solution the debate is raging across the
u.s. in Minneapolis where George Floyd
died the police chief suddenly called
off contract negotiations with his
officers the city has already voted to
dismantle its police force
I plan to bring in subject matter
experienced and advisers to conduct a
thorough review of how the contract can
be restructured in New York we're 350
members of the NYPD were injured in days
of violent protests and where an officer
was just charged with assault for
pushing a protester the police union
lashed out stop treating us like animals
and thugs and start treating us with
some respect we've been left out of the
conversation we've been vilified
it's disgusting
back in Washington the Trump
administration is reportedly weighing an
executive order on police reform that
could bolster legislation proposed by
Democrats all aimed at improving police
accountability if officers know they
have immunity they add with impunity in
this moment of reckoning few dispute the
need for change
Jackson prosecco Global News Washington
here in Canada the Deputy Prime Minister
was asked about systemic racism in
police forces here this is what she said
it is very important for all federal
government institutions including the
police to operate from an understanding
that systemic racism is a problem for us
here in Canada to not be complacent
about that and we have to work together
against it our Ottawa bureau chief put
the same question to the RCMP
commissioner and got a different answer
mercedes stephenson joins me now
Mercedes what did Brenda lucky tell you
well Donna it's an
question for the RCMP and it was clear
that the Commissioner was struggling to
answer it she says it's something she
thinks a lot about listen to what she
had to say
you know it's a question I haven't been
struggling with but I've been struggling
with the definition of systemic racism
and I when I think of unconscious bias
there is unconscious bias in the RCMP
most definitely and there is you know we
live in a society where the inequities
persist and police are part of that
society
I think systemically there's racism in
in most organizations and I don't think
the RCMP is immune to that Donna I asked
the Commissioner what she says to
indigenous leaders who say that they do
believe there is systemic racism and
that it's a significant issue in the
RCMP this was her response to whether
indigenous leaders are wrong when they
say systemic racism is a problem for the
police one thing I do think they're
wrong about is our will and our ability
to change because this is a moment a big
time in history and a big time for
police to step it up and the bar is set
high but so are my expectations for my
organization Mercedes without video
evidence of police brutality playing out
we rarely know about it you asked the
Commissioner about the incident and none
of it recently the man being
deliberately knocked over by the door of
a police vehicle what did she say well
exactly to your point Donna what happens
when there's not video and concerns
about how police officers are behaving
we asked her what she thought when she
was able to view this video that shocked
so many Canadians this is the
commissioners response we look at that
that type of incident and I say to
myself I need to go back backwards and
say do our members have the right
training do our policies and procedures
fall in line what circumstances well how
did that happen we have a lake our
commanding officer in the North has
mentioned in a previous interview we
have members who are working around the
clock and I'm not saying that's an
excuse but I'm just trying to find how
this can happen if she does think it's a
few bad apples and not systemic racism
does she have the authority to get rid
of those bad apples well that's such an
important question Donna because police
accountability is fundamental to trust
and the Commissioner does say that she
is concerned about maintaining Canadians
trust in the organization and wants to
continue to increase that I asked her
how much power she has to hold officers
to account and this is what she had to
say about firing them we have a range of
disciplinary actions that range from
operational guidance to dismissal so we
I do already have those powers do you
think you should use them more often
well each case is taken on its own merit
we look at the aggravating and the
mitigating factors and we have in the
past we average on approximately 17 to
20 members a year that are that leave
the force because of their actions and
Donna that issue of trust and
accountability so important all across
Canada especially in indigenous
communities that have seen a fractured
relationship with the RCMP Mercedes
Stevenson in Ottawa thanks there are
calls to defund the police and that
involves a range of ideas including
reallocating police funding to other
agencies that might be better trained
and prepared to respond to crises
involving mental health and substance
abuse as Ross Lord reports there's lots
of evidence armed officers aren't always
what's needed some details of their
deaths remain unclear but Regis Court
schinsky Paquette in Toronto and
Chantelle Moore in Edmonton New
Brunswick share a tragic distinction the
young women died eight days apart after
police were called in to check on their
state of mind at a time of distress
court schinsky Paquette fell from an
apartment balcony police say Moore died
after she threatened an officer with a
knife and he responded by shooting her
social justice advocates say the
tragedies underscore the need for a
change in who responds to those calls by
making a shift and saying well no the
people who we want to deploy in
circumstances where people might be in a
mental health
are helping professionals you know
mental health professionals social
workers ambulance attendants you know
counselors a national police union
suggests its members are reluctant
participants the Canadian Police
Association says the movement of recent
decades to take people struggling with
mental health out of institutions forced
police to respond to more calls it was
not something that we were trained to be
involved in to the extent that we become
involved in it
the group was represents 60,000 police
officers across the country says in
recent years there's been improvement in
mandatory training and awareness and in
de-escalating volatile situations
but the Association admits the mere
presence of a uniformed armed officer
sometimes escalates the situation you
will have people showing up to deal with
these issues particularly if we know
that the persons in the mental health
crises not wearing a uniform all of our
outreach teams that specifically focus
on mental health in the community
don't worry uniformed in both the Moore
and court schinsky Paquette tragedies
officers who responded were in uniform
it might be impossible to ever know what
if any impact that had on the outcomes
but advocates say sending people trained
primarily to project and exercise
authority is not an effective
arrangement
Ross Laura Global News Windsor Nova
Scotia
one of the latest targets of those angry
about oppression and racial inequality
is the Italian Explorer Christopher
Columbus the statue of Columbus was
toppled by demonstrators in Richmond
Virginia it was draped in a burning
American flag covered in red paint and
dumped in a lake other statues of
Columbus who sailed across the Atlantic
from Spain in 1492 have been beheaded
critics say his visit to the US is what
spearheaded the transatlantic slave
trade and led to European colonization
of indigenous people cops a popular but
controversial TV show has been cancelled
last week paramount Network temporarily
pulled the program as scrutiny on police
use of force reached a tipping point
yesterday the network confirmed there
are no plans to bring it back cops
debuted in 1989 and has been criticized
for glorifying arrests and selectively
editing footage in favor of the police
its producers have also been accused of
coercing suspects of crimes into signing
waivers to appear on television
the main test for kovat 19 put to the
test coming up why and when the test
could be ineffective
Ontario Premier Doug Ford and two
members of his cabinet have been tested
for kovat 19 the Education Minister
Stephen leche was first to be tested he
says he came into contact with someone
who had the virus leche says his test
has come back negative out of an
abundance of caution premier Ford and
Health Minister Christine Elliot also
got tested they're still waiting for
their results and didn't appear at the
media briefing today
Ford's nephew Toronto city councillor
Michael Ford has revealed he's tested
positive for kovat 19 the premiers
office says the two have not come into
contact with each other in the past 14
days a negative test does not guarantee
you aren't infected with the virus a lot
depends on when exactly you are tested
doing it too soon can give a false
negative and as Abigail Beeman explains
that has big implications as we open up
the economy a disinfectant plus
sanitizer is what we're using now some
Ontario restaurants are preparing to
reopen patios Friday with that as owner
eyghon gets nose comes an increased risk
of transmission you know I've had to ask
people to leave sometimes because
they've over consumed it's gonna be the
same sort of Jam if somebody's not
taking that seriously they're not
abiding by those sort of things they
gotta leave because the health and
safety of our staff is incredibly
important a new research out of Johns
Hopkins University suggests more people
could be walking around sick than we
think showing the main type of corona
virus testing produces at least one in
five false negatives on infection day
one a test is completely ineffective by
day five when symptoms typically start
the false negative rate hits 38 percent
that drops to 20 percent by day eight
before climbing back up you have someone
where you really think they have a high
probability of being infected you
shouldn't just kind of rest easy once
you have a negative test personal having
these kind of results is just that you
know we are definitely missing part of
the picture virologist Benoit Barbeau
says so much is still unknown about
koban 19 and there are so many
variables until we can find a better
standardized test people should get
tested more than once
coupled with false negatives the mystery
of asymptomatic transmission the World
Health Organization forced to walk back
comments that asymptomatic people posed
little to no risk now saying the science
isn't settled they're out there for sure
we cannot detect them they don't know
that they're infected there might
represent an important element in this
printing of the virus keep all this in
mind as provinces take more reopening
steps but Barbeau says it shouldn't stop
people from living more normal lives
heads isn't worried about people staying
home out of fear we have no doubt we'll
be full it's about managing those people
he's more worried about people not
taking the pandemic seriously enough
abigail Beeman global news Ottawa some
good news for families whose loved ones
live in long-term care homes in Nova
Scotia as of June 15th visitors will be
allowed again the visits must take place
outside though visitors will be screened
people must keep two metres apart and
non-medical masks must be worn the
Premier says it's a start I know this is
not exactly what you were hoping for and
we understand your craving for that
long-awaited hug we're not there yet but
sitting in the fresh air and a visit
with your loved one is a good first step
Nova Scotia reported no new cases of
kovat 19 today in only five active cases
of the virus Canada gets called out
ahead Greta toon burg sends her
complaints to the UN
you are watching global national there
is an update tonight on that humpback
whale found dead after swimming up the
st. Lawrence River to Montreal Quebec
researchers pulled it from the water and
say they found early evidence the whale
may have been hit by a boat the whale
had some signs of trauma so in my toma
on on the under the skin and on the on
the muscle accumulation of blood which
is actually suggestive of a trauma by a
boat researchers say its stomach was
empty they're hoping a full necropsy
will explain exactly why it died
climate activist Greta tun burg known
for castigating world leaders on climate
change is calling out canada the 17-year
old signed a letter from youth activists
and climate scientists they're urging UN
ambassadors from small island states to
push Canada and Norway to commit to no
new oil and gas exploration or
production and to phase out existing
production the letter says we believe
candidates for election to the Security
Council must recognize the climate
emergency and be committed to act based
on the best available climate science
the group says Canada pays lip service
to climate change but keeps expanding
fossil fuel production and subsidizing
oil companies Canada is going up against
Norway and Ireland for the two seats
available in next week's election to the
UN Security Council to win they need the
backing of two-thirds of UN member
nations case closed for Sweden's
murder-mystery next why the killers been
named but not punished
warm wishes are pouring in for Prince
Phillip today on his 99th birthday to
mark the milestone Buckingham Palace
released a new photo of the Duke of
Edinburgh and Queen Elizabeth
they are longevity personified they've
been married for 72 years it was taken
at Windsor Castle where the couple are
isolating during the pandemic they
celebrated with video calls to family
and the palace released some other
family photos today revealing some
candid moments of their long life
together including their royal visit to
Canada in 1951 for 34 years a
high-profile murder mystery has
intrigued Sweden tonight the death of a
former prime minister Olaf Palma is case
closed
Palma was shot back in 1986 while he was
walking home from the movies with his
wife with no security detail more than a
hundred people were suspected of
committing the crime today officials
revealed the man they say pulled the
trigger prompting a sense of relief and
frustration crystal commencing reports
on why it could generate a whole new
round of conspiracy theories he was a
social democrat who spoke critically of
the u.s. over the Vietnam War and called
apartheid in South Africa
a politically gruesome system Olaf Palma
had enemies and the hunt to find his
killer has been as notorious in Sweden
as his assassination this is one of the
biggest police investigations in the
world it's often compared with the
assassination of JFK and even also with
the Lockerbie bombing speaking through
an interpreter the head investigator and
chief prosecutor shared news the world
has been waiting decades to hear they
identified this man Stig Engstrom as the
shooter he worked at an insurance
company on the same street where the
shooting took place he put himself front
and center claiming to be a witness
Palma was shot in the back at
point-blank range and there were
apparently several witnesses but
authorities didn't present any evidence
connecting instrum to the murder I feel
confident about our conclusions but I
will not have the possibility to present
it to a court there won't be a trial
instrum ended his own life in 2000
previously it was thought that Christer
Pettersson was the killer his conviction
was overturned partly because of a lack
of evidence the killing has been
shrouded in rumor and speculation
conspiracy theories involve everything
from South African security forces to
rogue Swedish police with far-right
beliefs it Knutson a toma a national
trauma is how the current Prime Minister
described Palma's assassination
adding he hopes the wound can now heal
Sweden lost more than a top political
figure father and husband on that
February night Palma and his wife had no
security the feeling was that the
streets were so safe even the Prime
Minister could go for a late-night
stroll after a movie Cristal commencing
Global News London
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is the village of Harris
Saskatchewan incorporated in 1909 we'd
love to see your Canada please email it
to viewers at global national calm and
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye bye
[Music]